i just want to start with congrats on
the movie i thought you both did such a
great job in this um
uh jessica i've asked you this question
before so i'm just going to ask it to
your partner in crime today um ray is if
someone has actually never seen anything
you've done before uh what is the first
thing they should watch and why i i i
don't know i i i'm embarrassed to to
know what to tell people to watch i
guess
what comes into my head is is grand
budapest hotel i don't know why because
there's a
it's such such a great film in its own
right as a film apart from whatever i do
in it but
um
i i i like it because i thought wes
anderson saw a sort of comedic thing
that i could do in his particular way
and his world so
and i think the film has wonderful
humanity and wit and uh very unusual
very unusual films i i would say that's
just come out top of my head so funny
that's the last time i spoke to you was
for that movie of all things for you to
say but anyway for both of you what is
the quickest you signed on to a project
and why
the quickest i signed on is i was at the
venice film festival
and a friend of mine came up to me and
said
i'm getting texts from james gray
and he you know he knows you're at this
party and he wants to know if you'll do
this film
and i
just i had james's number in my text so
i just texted him i said of course i'll
do your film i hadn't read the script
yet i knew he wanted to make a story
about his life
so i that was the quickest it was like i
you know james and i hadn't even spoken
i hadn't read the script yet but i knew
it was about his childhood and um it was
a passion project for him and
and i was very happy
you know to be a part of it
right
i guess it would have to be schindler's
list i guess i mean i
i um
you know i had met
stephen briefly and as one of many
people he was meeting and then
i didn't even i wasn't even i mean i
just wanted
the part was great clearly and when the
offer came through it was a no-brainer i
mean i
i didn't i just
it was in it it was a wonderful
wonderful well i think there is moments
you're lucky you could be lucky to have
as an actor when you're asked to be part
of something that feels like it's going
to be
quite momentous i mean stephen's it was
going to be his
his passion work i think and
no it was a no-brainer i just was
delighted she said yeah i didn't even
say yes didn't even need to say yes it
was a given
i i i completely understand um jumping
into why i get to talk to you guys today
uh i would imagine that there are you
guys both get sent a lot of scripts what
was it specifically about this script
and this story that said i need to do
this
i had read the novel years before i
loved the book um
and i tried to get the rights to the
book actually because
it seemed so
important and it felt like a great it
could be a great film
um
the rights were taken so i kind of just
you know forgot about it a little bit
and then
it came my way again and i heard that
john mcdonough was involved
who i just i love his writing and i love
what he does as director and then i got
a text from rafe telling me that he was
gonna
do it and i was like okay i'm in
so um i was i i loved the character all
the way from the novel and then i loved
the people involved i think you know we
i imagine we both sent scripts all the
time and
i think within two or three pages of a
script you either you're either
interested or you're not and sometimes
you have to read through something
you're not enjoying because you've got
to give someone an answer
but this i remember just the there was
an economy to the writing there was a
danger a kind of witness a dark sense of
humor the characters yes yes yes we
could all say they're unlikable but
there was a sparkle to the dialogue i
mean good dialogue whatever the
characters are is just attractive you
just hear the crackle of something that
is
has a bite on the ear it has has a
dramatic punch and that's what the
script had and the setting of course and
what and how it evolved and i just
and the part the part had a great arc to
play so the combination of the part
john's work i
admired that very much to them
[Music]
his early work got the guard and calvary
particularly
um and so
yes it was it was the writing i mean i
you know i think i think we both
probably are at a stage where
you don't know how a film is going to
pan out i mean i i think you've just got
to follow your gut about something that
appeals to you as an actor because of
the combination of factors involved but
you know who knows you can forever say
you know people say oh the script has
great commercial possibility well no one
knows
no one there
but you've got to follow the
voice inside i am i've said this
many times but i'm a big fan of both of
your work um i really enjoy watching you
on screen and i'm just curious when you
have
i love talking to actors about the way
they like to work if you guys both have
say a really big scene on a monday and
you know it's a challenging moment or a
challenging scene how early on are you
preparing for that scene is it weeks out
is it before filming begins could you
talk sort of tell me a little bit about
your process when you know you have
something really big to do on a monday
i guess for me it depends on what's
challenging about it if it's challenging
because it's a ton of dialogue then
absolutely i'm spending my weekend or
even maybe a week before like if it's an
aaron sorkin thing i'm
i'm i have to be syllable perfect i know
before i get on that set with aaron um
so it's then yes i am working on it but
if it's like a dramatic scene
i try not to think about it at all
because i do a lot of my work before i
arrive on set when i'm on set i want to
be just open to the actors around me and
malleable and
sensitive
and if i pre-plan things or if i
exhaust myself with anxiety
i find that i'm not as open
to whatever the moment is i've also i've
since become more zen-like
with acting than i used to be
in the beginning i felt like i had to
try to figure out how to control things
you know this idea oh this has to happen
at this time so i need to make sure that
happens
and now i've just realized whatever i'm
feeling in the moment my character's
feeling
so whatever it is it always makes sense
for the character to be feeling the same
thing
um and getting out of my own way and
allowing myself to just be present for
what shows up i've found has
been a great gift to me
yeah i i completely agree with
everything jessica said i feel that you
get to a point where you
you can't control everything you're in
the hands of the director and the editor
and you i mean it's wonderful if there's
a director that's sympathetic to to the
actors being present but i mean
um
anthony mingler was wonderfully
sympathetic to
what his actors might give you know he
didn't try to control i think
um it's great when you're in the hands
of someone who's who's allowing stuff to
happen i mean john john was like this
although he was a very tight schedule so
i think he
he i i knew he was under the cosh as it
were under the pressure so
i mean that we didn't have maybe just by
the sheer
tightness of the schedule perhaps we
didn't have the time we might have
otherwise have had with a bigger budget
film i don't know i i still feel though
that when we were there we had times
just seems my memory of the scenes with
jessica is that we were
enjoying playing off of each other and i
totally agree with you jessica about the
thing about being present and feeling
the current flow
between and not and i and i also agree
if you have a lot of dialogue that's
really important especially for a script
where the the precision of the dialogue
is is is is a real factor that is
precisely spoken as written you've got
to do the homework the few days before
the sunday before
but you don't want to if you've got a
big dramatic scene which involves anger
or tears or some big climactic moment of
catharsis in the character i think
you've got to be careful you certainly
don't you certainly don't want to
practice it alone and as it were done it
in your bathroom and not on that you
know
you you want to you want to just sort of
hopefully you you've thought about it a
lot and you've you know you've n you've
nudged into the lines of what it might
be but you don't want to
you want to let it come to you for the
first time on the day and the cameras
are rolling and that note i need to wrap
i'm just going to say again congrats on
the movie thank you so much for giving
me your time thank you nice to see you
you